furniture with an element of surprise
this dresser by ferruccio la vie ani is
called whole the Italian designer uses
many of his designs to scrutinize the
classic principles of style like clear
lines symmetry or purity inform capital
de volta d I try to give on my objects a
special aesthetic or artistic note
equipped with this design I feel a
little bit like the rebellious son from
a good family who brings his grandma's
heirlooms into a squatters house he
lives with them in a totally different
way even lost romualdo ferruccio la vie
on ease newest project good vibrations
is still just a draft on his computer
the inspiration for deformed furniture
came to him through video interference a
lot of places like a son of a stop to
benefit I got the idea to have a piece
of furniture in the house that looks as
if it's distorted missile think that the
vibration that really hits you when you
pass by day pasa con las cosas but first
the designer had to convince his client
of the idea when they signed their
mouths were gaping open like this since
then la vianney has been working full
force the first distorted wardrobe has
to be finished in time for the Milan
furniture fair which opens next week
this wooden table is called toya or
tablecloth
la vianney likes to play with the
appearance of objects and the contrast
between individual elements like in this
sideboard called evolution en villa what
irony is important in my work this table
for example is called bedini ow that's a
dialect word for joke but I don't want
to be funny at all costs irony always
has to suit the product so I'm more
reserved la vianney works for famous
manufacturers for pots Carini he
designed these lamps called orbital
and supernova pero cheer love eonni has
been art director for the cartel company
for 23 years his lamp orgy from 2003 is
a best-seller ferruccio has also worked
for Dolce & Gabbana designing for
boutiques restaurants and bars he knows
both designers from his college days
maybe China me badly he's one day they
tell me we've noticed that we have a lot
of things from you and wouldn't it be
easier if you just designed them
straight for us without us first having
to look for your products merito della
valle comparable java la vianney has his
work cut out in the final days before
the Milan furniture fair he rushes from
one client to the next on top of that
his distorted furniture collection has
made the headlines journalists are
standing in line to interview him but he
doesn't want to be branded because of
his style no magic wand oh mia fede
analytic i just don't like it when
people put labels on me like neo-baroque
or the guy with the distorted furniture
I want to be perceived as an all-around
designer this is his collage sofa from
2012 its a mix of style and epochs that
people can put together themselves it
sells for about 10,000 heroes
well look KEO st. prey of course I
always want people to find what I make
attractive don't look but not because
they see the signature belongs to me
that looks like but because they like it
okay cause if they then say oh that's
from la vianney that's when I'm most
happy at 7p Brandon this mosaic
signboard is to be finished before the
Milan fair the largest and most
important trade fair of its kind in the
world it's just one of many new designs
by ferruccio la vie ani
you